I'm Leyna messy I let my football speak
for itself I learned that I'm more like
a messy type like let my football do the
talking you know I'm the best I got the
trophy this year
[Applause]
cilona we didn't mean to put you in
front and center but unfortunately all
the corners were taken too quickly I am
very happy for Lucca that he won the
Ballon d'Or it's my job to make sure
that all the players on the team are
happy like I've noticed Messi has been a
bit down since the World Cup
[Music]
hey you guys sorry gerotor bailed but
thanks for taking the rest of us out now
you are just like your season football
they see my veins also groans dear
Christian oh we had so many epic
classical's together but this will
always be how I remember you man I
haven't seen Leo these frustrated since
after every single international
tournament I don't call them free kicks
i call them free goals they say I should
ask Ronaldo to dinner because he is the
only person who understands you know how
it feels to always be around worst
players are you excited and know can I
get a little help I can't do this by
myself
we are not the same okay I am a brand
and you are just like a a football robot
or something
yeah run away like you ran away from La
Liga as much what did you say we are
messing we are these are fake titties
are when we are not blowing three gold
leads we are we are messy or we are
messy it's time to show this but we are
so much better than Cristiano
ladies and gentlemen my wife Shakira I
[Applause]
will not promote this cartoon but I will
subscribe to be our football to support
the Champions